[Music]  it's the news overload  got a denver i got a ring finally like  one of them doorbells  we had it for like a week and uh  yo we got we had our first visitor on  our porch  uh yes so this this my crib and  it's a white girl look like she's going  to sarah mclaughlin concert  going through my [ __ ] yeah but yeah she  uh  she she crept up and it's going through  there and i was like you know cause my  immediate you know  you know i got some bear spray if you  catch somebody on your ring  can you bare spray them on your porch  bro and it's just like first of all  let's be honest  i really don't care about you stealing  my oat milk i just want to see what bear  spray does to somebody  [Music]  i just wanna see  [Music]  can you show me  [Music]  can you tell me  i still live in media